another incident of alleged race racial
bias at starbucks is stirring new
outrage a black man claims he was denied
access to a bathroom at a los
angeles-area store even though a white
man was given the entry code
neither were paying customers shel
miller is at the philadelphia starbucks
where the controversial arrest of two
black men has spurred protests Michelle
good morning good morning well that
incident in Los Angeles County along
with the one here has left Starbucks
struggling with accusations of racism
from coast-to-coast now both events
appear to have started when a Starbucks
employee refused to allow black men into
the stores restrooms once the day
happened this past weekend in
Philadelphia that's when I say anything
happened to me in the newly resurfaced
video a white Starbucks customer named
Weston tells Brandon Ward he had no
problems getting access to the bathroom
yes what a code and they just gave it to
you right before you made a purchase
yeah Ward who was refused the code
minutes earlier then confronts a
Starbucks manager about the apparent
double standard business this is not
your business though okay you may be
permanent but you're not that you're not
you're not a security guard escorted him
out before police arrived it should have
been a sign right there I say a whites
only because that's how they treated it
Ward originally posted the video of his
encounter on Instagram in January but
it's received new attention this week
have you seen the video coming out of LA
it's in the Starbucks incident happening
there Starbucks CEO Kevin Johnson would
not answer questions about the latest
video he was in Philadelphia meeting
with the city's mayor and police chief
amid growing outcry and protests over
the arrest of two black businessmen in a
starbucks last week
[Music]
the men were denied using the store's
bathroom because they weren't paying
customers when they refused to leave a
manager called 911 apologized and wants
to meet with the men now there's been
some calls for us to take action in the
store manager
I believe that blame is misplaced in
fact I think the focus of fixing this I
own it now the Starbucks our Starbucks
says that the manager who called 911 at
this store no longer works here but the
company declined to say whether or not
she was fired left on her own or simply
was transferred to a different location
Gale all right Thank You Michele